[Music]
streaming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
street
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh hello
it's monday welcome back to the break
room our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know uh we hope you joined us here
this weekend maybe some of you have just
been waiting waiting for the show to
come back on from our marathon coverage
on saturday of d23 uh and we're going to
talk about d23 more today we're also
going to talk about uh the captain
america new world order casting news uh
the potential of john cheadle never
coming back to the mcu ever ever again
we'd be cheated out of that
cheese don't don't you can cheat on me
all you want
uh
it's harder for a rich man to get into
heaven than it is for
kevin feige to pass through the eye of
don cheadle that's right that was rough
it was serious that's a long story
around there
feed him for a lifetime give a man a
cheetal feed him for a day
there you go uh we're also talking about
daredevil born again being a fresh new
series no reruns there uh and we're
going to be rejecting some thunderbolts
much like uh val already did uh but
before we get to that i'm brandon who
cares the rest of the panel today is koi
jondro hey
fresh off to e23s 87 minutes of avatar
oh so much so much so much avatar and
finally back in the studio
jessica clements you guys
we had several days in a row of just
boys on this show so many boys shows
sweaty i'm here to get ready
for
you eating spicy food around a bunch of
dudes sweating already oh yeah it was
real locker room
but now we're all sensitive that's my
chat going
they're also going wild for the man to
my left tommy bechto what's up my mug
thugs how we doing oh mandatory fun mug
little update on that in just a few
minutes yeah we will update you on the
mud competition that's been going strong
but first let's address our redemptions
folks it's monday that means monday
motivations and not just any monday
motivations we got the wheel involved
you can see it back there somewhere uh
for every hundred dollars we get in
super chats we'll spin the wheel and
give you a sweet motivational speech uh
i'm not doing one for free i'm just
gonna give them a sample tell them what
it looks like i wrote them like
different
characters or people will have to be
given the motivation okay so that would
be a motivational speech as olivia
wilde's agent and this is i might say
something like
listen
this isn't for olivia this is for the
the people in the chat
you're all garbage oh my god what you've
done is toxic garbage behavior you
this is simply to the chat who i believe
are all bad people who probably spent
all weekend looking for coupons to get
dollars off their gas station hot dogs
but it was too much for them
so trash bags
donate a little money and get a pep talk
oh my goodness yeah we'll be doing those
monday motivations uh do we need to
update them on the mugs right now we do
give them an update on the mugs guys uh
as predicted by me uh and basically
all major mug experts out there in the
mug journalism world oh okay it was a
blowout folks mandatory fun mug one i
think we sold five thousand of these
whoa do we have that many i no we don't
we there's a back order of six years
wait you're telling me i need to get
back to the wheel and start spinning
that's right we need you to keep making
these awesome androids
you're back in the ceramic level
however i want to say this
to my friend my collaborator
my partner zach huddleston yeah
the morbid time mug
was a great mug
and for and it will become a collector's
item however it's not done being sold
yet
you can get
the it's more than time mug
till the end of the day all right
leaving it for sale okay until midnight
if you want to be one of the last owners
of this mug that many have used it's a
trash receptacle as a toilet
as a place to put things they don't want
to think of i someone put their
grandfather's ashes my grandfather was a
real toxic guy
so they shoved them in the mug anyway
you can get this mug one last time
that's right so midnight tonight but
guess what this mug is available
going forward baby you can get your
mandatory fun mug we're going to sell
tons of mugs today baby you're not going
to believe it but don't forget to do the
super chats either because if i don't
see that money honey i go hide under the
desk okay you go hard under the desk
i chase this video
i'm always hard under the desk oh my
gosh oh god i'm going to get more more
complaints
the competition was fierce i think zach
couldn't even show his face in the
office
i sprayed him with silly string
i couldn't watch any of the break room
last week which made me really sad
because i just kept missing it with the
time so is that what all the videos were
with like you dressed up as a clown i
don't know what you're talking about
okay okay so yeah so check out
newrockstarsmerch.com uh today's your
last day to get this soon to be
destroyed
if you want to buy either mug i i
understand if you buy the morbid type
mug for its collector's value but yeah
just as i remember
remember as i've been saying it's very
brittle it'll break in your hand and cut
you very badly whereas this mug solid as
an oak tree well this mug if you take a
sip out of it you get a little happiness
from zach oh that's right a little
happiness was like keep it in the case
mint in boxing conditions
yeah yeah we'll we'll get a we'll get a
ranking on it before all of our uh
really intense fans get mad we should
get to them yeah yeah let's get to those
headlines baby
did the graphic play he's playing right
now
you guys
everybody but me
everybody under the sun but me
everybody's grandma uncle aunt went to
d23 but specifically cory brandon and
tommy we're all present at the mega star
wars marvel lucasfilm panel and before
we jump into the headlines we thought
we'd break down the d23 panel especially
for myself because i wasn't there in
five minutes so we have a timer that
we'll put up and i just want to hear you
guys quickly tell me we got everything
that happened okay we don't get a lot of
time first up it was lucasfilm where
kathleen kennedy and diego luna
presented the final trailer for andor
next up the cast of willow showcased the
new teaser and introduced my boy
christian slater to the cash will
premiering november 30th just in time
for my birthday we got an update on two
star wars animated projects the bad
batch and tells of the jedi from dave
filoni uh with bad match coming out
january 4th i believe or yeah january
4th and details of the jedi uh dropping
all of their shorts and all of our
shorts with excitement on october 26th
it looks great baby yeah those are going
to be stories about ahsoka and dooku
right six little stories uh we also
found out that production is well
underway on the skeleton crew which
according to director john watson writer
christopher ford uh is going on and we
also got an epic trailer for mandalorian
season three which is out now on the
internet if you haven't seen that looks
great so excited that shot of those
those mandos jumping out of them
team six shots
that's how they got osama baby yeah and
to close out the lucasfilm panel
they showed us a look at indiana jones
five yeah directed by james mangold and
this is coming from a man who has done
the biggest hole in the earth and buried
every copy of kingdom of the crystal
skull i could get my hands on that yeah
in that hole and then filled it with my
own piss and feces yeah all right just
like this
this indiana jones 5 looks like it's
going to be great yeah uh it's got old
indiana jones it's got young indiana
jones we don't know where shyla buff is
who cares uh the la the live audience
was totally wowed every other director
and writer that came out for the rest of
the whole panel mentioned the indiana
jones stuff they're all blown away
harrison ford was moved he was crying uh
phoebe waller bridge had a lot to say
and she looks like she's gonna be great
in the film yeah i love her yeah she she
looked great she looked like she was in
love with harrison it wasn't great it
was a real spark between it was a real
moment
harrison even said like this is a good
one yeah referring to the fact that he's
going to kick your ass yeah yeah he also
said i'm done i'm done uh getting him
i'm falling down
for you guys so this will be his last
run but it looked awesome uh then they
kicked off the marvel studio uh section
of the panel with kevin feige walking us
through a melee of footage and
announcements but not before an epic
live performance of roger's the musical
which was so good and if you're
listening to me bob chapic put up rogers
the musical at the hyperion theater
disney california adventure you coward
put it up there today you're in l.a my
god there's 9 000 people that could be
in that cast including four right here
yeah put it up put it up fill up the
theater space
come on the show we got a great first
look at ironheart by executive producer
ryan coogler uh that's coming out on
disney plus next year the audience was
wowed by the trailer for marvel studios
first special presentation werewolf by
night we've been waiting for this it
looks great it looks so different so
cool very excited to see it question
yeah so where was when i remember how we
were like it wasn't actually set in
stone we just kind of heard rumors of it
so this is like our first actual like
set in stone that's happening yeah my
trailer is out it comes out in october
it's legit like they were not talking
about it
i think they were hiding it it looks
great it's a special presentation so i
think it lists exists outside the
universe of everything i don't know what
to do as well at midnight
we'll talk about that one more
i and yeah they put out that trailer and
they also put out the secret invasion
trailer we got a little bit of a longer
clip eric's talked about that in his
videos uh but that that looks awesome
and it reminds me so much of captain
america winter soldier i'm so excited
torture oh my gosh i love torture i
can't wait looks so good all right
research this in five minutes let me see
what i can do we didn't get a ton of
information on armored wars we did get a
logo and assurance we'd be seeing some
new suits in tech and production on loki
season 2 is well underway and the cast
came out to give us a sneak peek of what
to expect we also got a look at echo
which should stream next year on disney
plus in addition to that we got an
extended look at black panther o'connor
forever coming out november 11th and an
official confirmation kevin feige that
matt shackman will in fact be directing
fantastic four we got some casting news
for cats america new world order with
tim blake nelson returning as the leader
after a 14-year absence the longest gap
in the mcu owns the entire run of the
mcu today and the marvel portion closed
out with the announcement of the
thunderbolt team and a first look at the
and we marvel's that that was wonderful
was a pretty extensive look at avatar
the way of water
we got to see a bunch of scenes in three
dimensions
most movies are too but this one is
three-dimensional
we got fun glasses we got the reason
that's it baby
oh we did it
they let us keep the claws
that's true the glasses we did give back
but we got nice prints
nice prints yeah uh the way of water
looks interesting it looks a lot like
the first avatar it sure does
the water
does the water looks very cool would you
like an aquatic bird as opposed to a
flying bird yeah i like aquatic birds
we'll save that those are our executive
avatars we'll be talking tar
later i like calling it tarn
and some other headlines from d23 disney
had a lot of announcements of their own
i'll run through some of those real
quick they announced disney announced
films including hocus pocus two
disenchanted which i really like making
her the bad guy and that's so smart uh
peter pan and wendy mansion mufasa the
lion king or if you follow follow erica
on twitter it's known as joe mufasa the
lion king it's a little prequel uh a
snow white movie with gal gadot the
little mermaid uh plus the zootopia plus
series a series called owaju a movie
called strange world and a animated film
called wish are they doing another
willow uh
he announced the game
he was speaking i did nine minutes yeah
pulling in like a bunch of uh different
movies well yeah which is watercolor and
cgi so they're blending the old animated
style by hand drawn and then they're
using 3d rendering so it's actually like
i've never seen animation quite like it
it kind of looks like mo-cap mixed with
the old kingdom heart style like oh no
yeah yeah i had like an original song
presentation and it's all about the star
that you wish upon in the world of
disney so it kind of unites those worlds
and they said it was like easter
egg-tastic and it's got alan tudyk
they're good luck charm as a goat it
like immediately rose to my number one
mosque
this is the the narrative decade of
multiverses everyone's given it
everywhere try it out everyone's giving
that a whirl zach says he went to high
school with joe mufasa
i don't think that's true that's pretty
cool
i think that's pretty cool zach did go
to a high school for lions which was
very interesting
no high school for liars oh no i
misunderstood i just understood like
when he said his mug was quality
it is it's
not a few more hours sorry pixar also
announced a couple new projects
including elemental a series called win
or lose a film called elio elio i don't
know you pronounce it hello hello and
then inside out too
where they got rid of two emotions they
got rid of disgusting fear because she's
becoming a teenager and for some reason
you lose disgust and fear and get shame
and lust actually i think it's because
disgust and fear want a little bit of
money
who knows
yeah that's true we'll never know we'll
never know uh
ah oh that water tastes awful out of
this morbid time mug no it tastes
delicious it tastes like zach's
happiness give me the red
what happiness oh i missed the first
part
some other headlines uh to start off our
week uh we got our first look at
werewolf by knights monster in color not
from the tree
i always said you could store it that
was so that was so strong
i think it's been undone you got a
week's vacation pull it together
came back snorting came back snorting
uh did you go to columbia i am told that
that's what the mugs do taste like
[Applause]
um
so the werewolf by night trailer was all
in black and white but they at the
disney parks panel which had a lot of
interesting stuff they announced a new
ride they're going to do at avengers
campus here in uh california adventure
at disneyland uh resorts and it's going
to be a ride that goes through
multiverses it involves a multiverse the
enemy is like a king thanos thanos who's
won he's got this cool crown an old old
man beard not living on a farm just
living it up uh and the right is gonna
involve different heroes from the
multiverse and variants coming together
to fight with you i assume somehow uh
but in this concept art for it we saw a
color image of both werewolf by night
and man thing man thing also being in
the werewolf by night trailer there's
the werewolf by night it looks like a
werewolf what do you know
looks great uh and there's man things
looking like green roots wait dash will
move a little bit and that's that's of
course uh the california adventure
version of spider-man that lives in
an avengers campus and they have like an
animated version of spider-man yeah
really cool i'm very excited for that
ride and probably three or four years
and i also feel like it'll be
interesting when we get the the sony
stuff to start cooking up more i feel
like yeah with that spider-man thing we
still haven't solved the mystery fd23 uh
it'll be curious to see how the the tv
rights versus the film rights and what
which trilogy they continue on who they
can put in there i'm sure andrew
garfield would love to be on the right
yeah i'd love to be on the ride i'd love
to go on a ride with andrew garfield
somewhere i'd like to know
that his deadline
is right there we're going to time
jessica out for 30 seconds on the new
rockstars chat 300. jesus what did you
do to get banned for 300 seconds
we don't need you on the show get out of
the chat for a million seconds if you're
gonna talk about jessica like that wow
it's okay i'm used to it our next step
clown not accepting bounds in the chat
piano
uh don cheadle confirmed that he's done
with marvel's contract uh he said an
interview quote i'm done with my
contracted years in the mcu so now it's
just like if something sounds fun and
i'm presented with it then yeah let's go
uh so you know
i would call this not a thirsty thespian
but uh fill the bag yeah
it's it's more so well i'm sure all of
their contracts get ended eventually and
it's like and he's been here for a
minute well yeah he might have been had
one of those old contracts like we need
you for the next 10 weeks i think it's a
little bit of a desperate dramatist he's
like oh i'm done or am i but i'm
probably done or am i
i'm all out of my contract i couldn't
come back not for not for less than 10
million dollars 10 million
i think it's a good testament to showing
like the quality of the work they expect
like the actors expect now and the
contracts are less and less that insane
15 movies situation so it seems like
we're gonna go straight from our moors
into secret invasion that was one of the
most interesting parts for me from the
panel was kevin feige really seemed to
stress that it was like a one-two punch
that our rewards led directly into the
secret invasion it's not the case in the
comics those continuities do not line up
at all but i'm curious if we have
something like you know justin hammer
who we all hope comes back for armor
wars and that person turns out to be a
skrull and maybe then you see why the
armor rewards like if star tech gets
leaked i wonder if the enemy gets it
like i wonder something that's going to
lead to us all being paranoid as a
society because i've been saying from
the jump we're going to have secret
invasion needs to happen before x-men
because we need to have a world that
hates and fears heroes so i think it's
going to be a really interesting trilogy
effectively it's a soft trilogy going
from armor war secret invasion new world
order because they also described
captain america four as a paranoid
thriller so i think we're just gonna be
going through an era of distrust for
heroes and distrust for these things all
setting up phase six i think it's more
interesting that you think the secret
invasion is gonna be the setup that
heroes are bad and not not the other
ones i mean if you have a bunch of
people that you think are good turn out
to be skrulls and if you have a hero
team that also turns out to be bad guys
okay because i was like i think in kang
you're going to start noticing people
are going to start being like we can't
fight we can't fight him it's going to
do like civil war where tony's like no
i'm out i'm not doing this and that's
when you see people actually show their
true colors but i think these are going
to be setting up kang right like these
are all beforehand and you're going to
start to distrust people 100 and we know
that especially from the clip that was
shown of black panther wakanda forever
like vibranium always the big uh kind of
mcguffin out there uh it's gonna play a
big role there what kind is vibranium
but also with the introduction of namor
uh
i i bet they're gonna find more
vibranium in the world and that's also
gonna add to the problem i think they're
gonna find more vibranium in the world
and they're going to render it inert i
think there's going to be a because
there's a storyline in the comics where
dr doom manipulates the world market to
basically make wakanda have to put
themselves in poverty by rendering all
uh vibranium inert so people can't take
its power so basically the whole world's
like we've got this thing now and then
they're like it fell into the wrong
hands boop so i'm curious if that's how
we get the new black panther like maybe
that's the last of the functioning
vibranium that would allow for some
doctor doom action it would be global in
scale which looks like that setup the
geopoliticalness and maybe when they're
out of that you know power structure
that's when neymar invades
maybe could be we'll find out koi
actually
is just audi now
i've read the script from black panther
it's right back as long as you're giving
it to us not real rejects
i gotta go you guys
you're not going
uh and our next headline captain america
ford director uh teased the leader's
villainous role in the film julius anna
mentioned in an interview with screen
rant in regards to the leader joining
the new world new world order he said
what's so great in this film is sam
wilson has an incredible adversary in
the leader played by tim blake nelson
very excited to hear he's coming back
this brilliant mastermind who's always
one two three four steps ahead i think
audiences as they watch the film will
never be able to see what's coming right
around the corner uh so it sounds like
it's gonna be a tough tough role do you
think that's a soft confirmation for
she-hulk having the leader because i was
like wait tip like nelson's you can't
just like throw them in right that's the
big theory it was like and frankie
almost kind of said it as like oh yeah
also like tim blake nelson's
the leader and everyone's like wait why
because we were in that room i was like
who's the short guy yeah yeah and i was
like oh tim blake nelson's back well
maybe maybe they do just appear in
captain america new world order because
we know his his original first time is
incredible hulk so it's not like he
needs to be ushered in like a meal again
but i yeah maybe they just throw him in
and we're like we all know we're all
aware yeah people didn't watch from that
i mean like people that were in a minute
or two
now right wait a minute could they do
that have they they've probably done
that before with other people right in
other movies
i don't think that long because emil is
the first one since i mean he he even
popped up in chiang chi as that's true i
mean they kind of are like by the way
because it's gonna be like that's a long
time yeah i i think keep an eye out for
the leader and she hope for sure uh we
might have to put that on our
predictions list when we do our fantasy
drafts uh our next headline uh shira
haas was announced to be playing sabra
in captain america new world order uh
there's an image of this uh
mattress
uh so yeah learning more about that film
i was so excited to see elijah bradley
coming back yes that was great so many
panels so happy to be there there's so
many people in it probably kept stealing
every scene from me and falconer soldier
like whenever he was oh yeah this feels
like it has way more of him and also the
kind of shifting of uh you know winter
soldier white wolf whatever want to call
them now over to thunderbolts and away
from new world order i was like oh
interesting interesting and then having
falcon probably take up the falcon
mantle like the new falcons yeah yeah
yeah
and like you know post flyboy and top
gun that boy loves his that's right a
lot of flying dudes wings oh yeah kevin
feige bitterly mentioned top gun
so angry that another movie was popular
that wasn't a marvel film yeah that
movie is rocky because the actor was
there and he was like so you were in
another movie where you were flying
around
he loves movies he doesn't want movies
beating his books and that movie beat
everyone's movie
fragrance we stayed very hydrated
brandon bought some liquid oh yeah i
bought caffeine yeah tommy and i was
taking care of tommy and i i left eric
on his own i was like this is our water
you can't have it we snuck into the
media room got some delicious
refreshments uh we did fragro thank you
thank you to all our super chatters out
there we see them coming in we will get
to them today yeah we gotta get through
all these things
what are we 33 away from a pep talk
we're so close to a pep 33 dollars away
from the wheel we get to spin it spin
the wheel it could be anything could be
anything could be anyone who knows who's
getting a pep talk today who knows uh
next headline uh deadline reporter uh
justin kroll tweeted about the
the lack of x-men updates
at the at the panel uh he said quote
this this film isn't happening for a
very long time talking about an x-men
film uh so outside of a writer being
tapped it's super unlikely any casting
decisions get made on that one for some
time now this is just a reporter going
off the sources he has i don't think
he's being given all the information i'm
sure they're talking about it i'm sure
they're thinking about it he was also
said an x-men movie it doesn't mean like
mutants can't show up otherwise well i
think we've been known that because i
keep bringing that out like we're
getting mutants we're just like getting
the x opera is a mutant in the comics so
it's like we're getting more and more
mutants coming in we'll be seeing
mutants in the coming weeks of chief
i think we'll be seeing mutants for the
next few years and i honestly think i'd
rather have it this slow burn way than
it just been thrown at us and i also i
want to say on the record this was the
first time i fell for the internet
and i'm the for the first time i was
like fantastic for coming x-men or
coming and i
think that is a really dangerous
precedent like i fell for it i made a
tick tock i was like tomorrow's the day
i think we need to really appreciate
what we have versus like complain about
what we don't because i was sitting in
that presentation wanting fantastic
support and x-men and that affected my
experience and as soon as i walked out i
was like no one told me this was coming
they don't owe me anything like there's
no reason we should demand and all these
people complaining about it we just had
10 new trailers released no other studio
in the world could even do that if they
wanted to and people were complaining
about a lack of thing that never was
promised i just think it's a really
slippery slope because if you're always
expecting too much you're always going
to be disappointed and that isn't going
to make good art and if people start
getting reactionary then they're going
to rush stuff that shouldn't be rushed
and then you get movies that aren't
feeling finished so i just slow your
roll trust in the process don't expect
things this is all a gift we don't owe
anyone art so appreciate the art you get
the exact opposite was for me where i
was like
i needed it no no no
i was like as soon as i my plane landed
as the marvel stuff ended and i was like
oh yeah but then it was the what got me
was the little mermaid
in that trailer i wanted to throw myself
through the window of the plane as it
landed i wanted to run to her i wanted
to find her and congratulate her
sebastian is he going to look like stone
crab with a
we'll see uh well well said cory and
jessica i picked your apology boy mine
is more like a little mermaid
hey i like the little mermaid yeah put
the little mermaid in avatar too that's
what i say combined all your swimmers uh
our next headline concerns daredevil
being born again uh it's not a season
four folks following the netflix story
charlie cox has been talking about this
he said quote my feeling is based on the
title born again i think that the sense
is that this is a new beginning it's
going to be different it's going to be
totally different it's going to be new
stories and new ideas it's a season one
not a season four so it's a whole new
thing which i think is the way to go if
you're going to do it again do it
differently and he kind of said the same
when him and vincent didn't afria were
on
this is a new story for us it's kind of
starting over so it'll be interesting to
see how they get into it my hope is that
it is an amalgamation because i've seen
a few interviews with him where he was
saying in 16 episodes we have the time
to do the more lighter tone as well as
the darker because daryl's a darker
character but he has levity especially
the mark wade run there's certain runs
where that that humor does come out of
the darkness and i think it's really
important to go into those expectations
because they're not getting a netflix
show we're not going to get that kind of
r-rated gruesomeness but i do think
they've learned a little bit from the
kingpin thing because because marvel
listens to the fans yeah and i do think
that kingpin going so aggressively
different made a lot of us go like
so i think it's actually a good thing
because we're going to land somewhere in
the pendulum is going to land better
with 16 episodes and i think that no one
knows this character more than charlie
cox and i think no one's more invested
than marvel going like okay we slipped a
little bit let's get this right i also
think with thunderbolts that's gonna be
a chance to make taskmaster more of what
we want like a lot of these things feel
like they can retroactively enhance and
i'm excited that's why i disagree when
you were like marvel listens to the
people i was like they didn't listen to
me about taskmaster they should i was
not listening to me about tasmania and
also yeah that's what happened to star
wars and then yeah yeah making a man
making
anybody we're all idiots
uh oh my god i'm so excited please don't
get me imagine listen to the people in
the chat
they came out of their dumpsters on
their mobile flip phones so they're
pre-built like they're burner phones
from kmart that they have to buy because
real cell phones require contracts and
credit and all of your credit scores are
under 300. i guarantee it's gonna need a
motivational
i'm fine with it not being the season
four of what was uh but it my thing is
if it's daredevil born again is it gonna
be close to the comics because daredevil
born again was really close to season
threes
and i love born again so much that i'm
like okay if you're gonna title it born
again please
be close to the comics but the season
three is too close to the comics i don't
know i just i don't know i don't want it
to be a season four but i do need it to
be close
i could be different the footage they
showed she-hulk was like really cool
balance yeah
you guys saw that yeah so like that
footage i feel like was comedic but it
wasn't like dark like it worked for both
it was like what happened
zach just said tommy finally admits he's
i have never not admitted that to be
fair go back i admit how stupid i am all
the time i told you i went to three
colleges no degree check the tape uh i
agree with all that all i want out of
the daredevil story is please skip the
part where he loses his powers they did
it every season i'm tired of it we're
good with the pearls guys no more pearls
i don't want to stop it before the
discussion but there is some debating
going on in the chat that uh
that either that we have implied that
the motivational speeches will come at
50. some of the written information is
that and so some people are saying we
owe them a motivational speech i don't
know it's up to you guys
we i don't want to set a precedent you
can do one if you want to do one look at
jessica do you feel like giving a
motivational no you do because i wrote
these for you all right
because you do good characters i'll do
one motivational speech because it's
monday and tommy's been mean to you so
we'll roll out one listen there's a
difference between being mean and being
get out of the way so you can see what
he's spending being mean and being
truthful let's hit it
the hunch to the hunchback to the
hunchback of notre dame of notre dame
the guy that goes to notre dame has a
bad
all right camera four
listen up
not everybody's born beautiful in fact
most of you
got hit by every branch of the ugly tree
on your way motivational time basting
that hey look at me
you know what i'm working with
i'm working with an la negative five and
a rochester two
that's basically a human turtle okay
there's not much about me that's
aesthetically pleasing my voice sounds
like coffee grounds thrown through a
blender a ninja blender hey
don't touch me i don't deserve to be
touched
just because you're ugly and most of you
are doesn't mean you can't find love and
maybe it's in art maybe you got to find
love in the trees around you maybe
another human won't even look at you
without barfing and quite frankly
i believe that to be true based on some
of the comments we get in the chat
you're vomit inducing however
just because you got a messed up back
just because your face one eye droops
lower than the other just because your
singing voice is more beautiful than
than your hair and everything else
working with you that means the human
experience can be enjoyed by you guys
don't go to bed every night thinking why
am i so ugly wake up every morning
saying wow
my crippled bent heart started beating
again today how lucky am i now let's be
honest most of you will never find true
love because you don't deserve it but
there is such thing as instant
gratification okay they're simple
pleasures you can go down to the
spearmint rhino for 20 bucks a girl make
you feel like a star for three minutes
okay so get those 20 bills out get down
to the local gentleman's club and feel
beautiful for just three minutes okay
you can do it gang
well let's get out to our main
discussion today and if you like that
we're going to our main discussion go
ahead and hit that like button if you
like it so much uh all this news coming
out of d23 we've been talking about uh
one of the things to me that was the
most exciting was like the trailer and
footage that we got for ant-man and the
watch
[Laughter]
take the camera off me take the camera
off you right now
oh my no someone someone said this hit
too close to home and i don't like it
motivational speeches folks oh man them
beads
yeah the angle and the wasp
was the most interesting to me
uh there because this is the film that's
kicking off phase five uh it's very
important to the multiverse saga as
kevin feige really
really emphasized and like
uh uh paul rudd was talking about how
this one feels very different you know
the first two are much lighter they're
definitely like on the more comedic side
yeah they're gonna go a little heavier
for this one uh the stuff in the the
clip that they showed it's similar to
what they showed at comic con it was a
little more extended right
we see that kang and and scott are
talking they're inside the quantum realm
presumably yeah some sort of ship or
home base kang has captured uh cassie
lang she's behind in a statue of costume
in her stench of costume uh but kang is
very clear he says a couple weird things
right he's like are you an avenger have
i killed you before i don't know how
this guy would know that how scott would
know that thing it's very weird but why
do we think
that
kang specifically needs 616 scott lang
to do a heist another heist the one
thing he doesn't want to do anymore i
got theories you got theories okay so i
think we see other no i'm joking
what if we see other avengers teams that
are more functioning fighting kang and
like we assume that our ant-man knows
about the multiverse deeper right so
maybe kang is used to avengers being
more worldly and that'd be a great way
to have like other more established
teams so he's like have i killed you
before because that he's used to
ant-man's knowing about this
other one and that's why he expects him
to be more intimidated because kenny
comes out like yo you should be afraid
of me and what a man isn't right i think
he's like why isn't this connecting so i
think the heist thing is why he didn't
hire hank pym or snapchat or any of
those things and the reason he
manipulates our
ant-man is because he's like uniquely
heisti yeah so like i think manipulating
him to do a heist versus other things is
why it's ours okay and i think the the
reason behind it is other ant-man know
more about
so is this like a good king no no this
is a definitely just forcing scott to do
this kidnapping
oh cause he's kidnapped oh okay now i
got it and i love that the scars look
like the mask yeah like i wanted the
mask i wanted the mask so bad you look
so much more comic accurate like the
chess piece looks just like the books
and the scarf and even you know from
loki where he who remains is very jet
almost like a court jester very simple
very loose with his body and his face
this kang was like serious one of the
best things they could do is jonathan
major is playing like 20 different kings
yeah because he is such range and him on
stage i was like what is this man he
came out uh dressed as mr vanessa buddy
summer vacation a deep cut for all you
theater nerds out there uh but basically
wearing like a huge trench coat
and every interview he's like a
different energy like jonathan majors
the man fascinates me so i want to see
as many kangs as we can so i can see the
multiverse through a person yeah do you
think we'll see like an urkel
game okay
is it as simple as
the very convoluted time heist figured
out in um end game an end game
kang somehow sees that and is like i
need that they're the only avengers that
pull them out yeah that's what john and
i were kind of talking about is like why
why
scott lang right if it's the powers of
ant-man that's a hank pym thing yeah
like scott lang doesn't know how to make
particles right uh but so why do you
need this guy is it that like every
scott lang and every multiverse is a
good thief yeah and he's like i know you
guys are good things he was a heart of
gold or was he is he the only ant-man
that's gone into the quantum realm and
he's like you've figured it out yeah
you're like you know what's going on he
also might think the only one that
survives the quantum realm he also might
think he's not true like you know what i
mean he's like oh you're the other hand
because in other ant-man universes it
might be hank pym like in the comics
first because like obviously they're all
in the comics but he might have just
misinterpreted his power set do you
think he'll take like a ravager
oh no like because that makes sense
right they're really good at doing
things
do we think this ties into the
multiverse like this is quantum mania
yeah and we know that the quantum realm
is weird and it might be a way to access
multiverses in a strange way
like how do we think this is kicking off
i mean we're seeing the multiverse saga
but this one is really kicking off
the plot yeah right this one jumps is
this one jumping
i don't correct me if i'm wrong i
thought i read this somewhere it
connects directly to the king dynasty uh
well it does in that
it kind of is introducing kang to the
main yeah well he said it launches the
events that lead directly that's right
because phase five kicks off with this
movie right and so i think this first
phase phase four of the multiverse saga
phase four total is the introducing the
concept of disparate universes and then
i think phase five is it all kind of
smooshing together and then phase six is
the the conflict awards etc i wish i had
a pen so it goes from so it has this
movie right it starts the phase five you
said yeah so it starts phase five and
then the ending of it will be king's
dynasty and everything in between will
just be leading up also together
yeah that's what i'm saying in space
five yeah phase six begins there might
be something right before fantastic four
as of now
kicks it off as of now but i don't
remember if that were the little line
yeah yeah it's literally like that's the
kick off for now but then it ends with
secret or ken dynasty and then some two
other things and then so much like
infinity war in game those are the you
know pockets and then like captain
marvel came between we're gonna get too
little
okay so it'll be very interesting i
don't know yeah it was a very
interesting
clip to to show yeah presumably might be
in the trailer it might be a clip that
comes out pretty soon but yeah i don't
know what it is about that scott lang
that makes them so special they were
really kind of
yeah i think people underplay that how
important scotland was to like
everything i always like when i
rewatched it i was like yeah we wouldn't
have uh we might have found out time
travel eventually but we definitely
didn't find it unless he came back he
was the first one to come out in game
like he really set everything in motion
and they they do really emphasize in the
film too that his daughter is very smart
and like she's the one that figures out
some technology without pim or janet
because she's working on it while
they're gone what if she what if he's
stuck in the quantum realm and she
accidentally unleashes him and he's just
the first ant-man king meets like what
if it's not by choice what if he's like
yo this girl like genie let me out of
the lamp and he's like i know ant-man
and i will take you out because i know
what ant-man are you know what i mean
like he's used to ant-man but it's just
the first answer he comes across i do
like that idea that he or that he's
never met a name every other ant-man has
died before he showed up oh god they all
got squished if if he's stuck in that
little city that we've seen yeah and we
assume people are yeah so if he's stuck
in there she accidentally lets him out
and then the first avenger he comes
across happens to be ant-man then it's
not as you know
we're assuming too much
well we love to assume too much here
it's the internet a new rock face
fantastic four coming next year it's
what we just did yesterday uh yeah and
if you're like coy and you get all
worked up about something and then
you're disappointed you know we hate
feeling down and like feeling kind of
disappointed and let out you sometimes
just gotta talk about it that's right
and that's like
why we would like to take a quick moment
uh to share a word from our sponsors at
betterhelp because we always want to
take care of those big juicy brains up
there keep them happy and healthy and
one good way to do that is through
therapy you know you could talk about
your disappointments you could talk
about the things that get on your mind
that bug you uh but maybe you don't want
to leave your house to do therapy it
stinks right well thankfully our friends
have better help offer online therapy
solutions and tommy you've used better
health i've been using better i've been
on that better health train i like how
you said talk about your disappointments
because 45 minutes a week i spend
talking about my disappointments with my
better health therapist and let me tell
you
they're bountiful the amount of
disappointments i have they're down
they're rich you got a lot of wins
they're they're gaining traction every
day and she tries to remind me that
within the disappointments there are
points
and to remember those points and learn
from them
and i don't and that's why i get new
disappointments and schedule new
appointments for my disappointments and
it's one big circle over and over again
anyway
better help is online therapy so you can
do it wherever you feel most comfortable
and they offer video phone and even live
chat therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to me i do i like them to see my
face i say look upon my face it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and brandon tell them about the deal
we're getting this tell them about the
deal you got it tommy our listeners our
viewers or however you consume this
media you can get 10 off your first
month of uh a better help at
betterhelp.com
breakroom again that's better
h-e-l-p-com
break room check it out we love therapy
if you want to give it a try please do
we recommend it so much uh before we
move on to our next step let's
acknowledge some of our super chatters
out there thank you all these super
chats we'll be getting today uh
smackaboo saying this is perfect for the
break room
uh it's wolverine spin me poppy trying
to get us there we're so close
six
elizabeth c saying i haven't seen you
guys uh live in a while love to all you
love to you elizabeth c and avril saying
did y'all hear i love a good y'all
though i like to put the apostrophe
before the all that's just me yeah did
you all hear about disney labeling
werewolf by night as a comedy i'm a bit
disappointed but what do you guys think
about it comedy i mean i think it's only
a comedy and that it's
an old style thing it looked pretty
terrifying a lot of horror and like
don't remember that uh yeah yeah trailer
in the middle of grindhouse
yeah that's a comedy it looked like that
kind of 30 40s horror i mean i guess
that's kind of a copy but i think it'll
be darker than we think and uh just like
very interesting kind of like
psychological horror type thing uh i
think it'll be a lot of fun excellent
it's time for mandatory fun what is it
what what was that tommy it's time for
my main drawing i can't get are you
saying booty beans
it's time for mandatory [ __ ]
yes
hit my graphic mandatory fun this
segment's so dynamic we put it on a mug
we put it up against an inferior mug it
squashed that mug it gave that mug a
beat down so i want you to all give me
your mandatory fun mugs a hug when they
show up and it'll be like hugging me
anyway mandatory fun is the segment
where i bring
three of my absolute best friends in the
world together to do a little fun that
they have no choice but to participate
in with hit the graphic again
[Applause]
it's much
like the phantom of the opera mandatory
fun
looms over the studio haunting singing
entertaining and much like the phantom
of the opera hit that image of sabra
yes
all right now
when we saw the first book it's never
smart i never said i was smart
why do you guys keep coming for tommy's
intelligence i said it's so stupid
the lowest percentile when it comes to
handwriting and hand strength
tensile strength but these wrists are
like iron iron wrists that would be the
name of my character
trust me
and they and they're smooth all right
continue we get the first lick of
thunderbolts uh at the thunderbolts
lineup we all went nuts for the bolts
yeah i didn't even mean to do that
i'm nuts for the bolts put it on a shirt
stupid unfortunately not all of our
favorite troubled mcu soles could be
included contessa
van tina
de fontaine was kind enough to actually
hire us there's a little bit of a
writer's room to send out some rejection
letters to some uh some of those
anti-heroes in the mcu that we
hate to love and love to hate yeah yeah
not all of our villains made it to the
thunderbolts lineup yeah or heroes or
heroes
i hope bucky's going back to the bad
side i don't like nice bucky
i like to be keeping them accountable i
don't know like i like
sweet sweet spa buckingham
these are official rejection letters
great stationery crazy handwriting yeah
absolutely child like handwriting again
i love if she lives in a gordon hills or
the the office in a glory don't give
away our address it's not uh this is
allegra's valentina allegra's address uh
dear phineas mason aka the tinkerer oh
we appreciate your interest in joining
the thunderbolts unfortunately we are
unable to offer you a spot on the team
at this time we had over 2500 applicants
and sadly only a few spots could be
filled
we would like you to and we would like
to invite you to enroll in our community
college program tiny both school for
little stinkers who mean well
so there's that option for i love it
please don't hesitate to apply again in
the future
there will be openings oh sincerely
now oh there will be openings what is
this some kind of suicide squad what
that means i like it
i like that one also i want to go to the
community college you want to go to the
uh tiny bolt school for a little
stinkers who mean well yeah come a
little stinker put it on a shirt all
right
i got mine i got mine so she asked me to
write it to kate bishop oh okay bishop
okay bishop applied so it says dear kate
bishop thank you for tirelessly applying
again and again and again well we
appreciate your interest in joining the
thunderbolts we regret to inform you we
cannot take such an amateur hero i know
what you're thinking ghost is an amateur
ghost is on the team well she has powers
you have a limited supply of arrows also
i think there's some sort of love thing
going on between you and elena our
leader we can't afford that distraction
maybe if interested in spring we hold
interviews to be our unpaid intern and
editorial please apply julie oh well i
guess she put her other names
oh
did she put her
is that some sort of alien i think so
it's our
multiverse
yeah delicious uh i got one it's uh dear
mr blonsky thank you for your interest
in joining the thunderbolts quite
frankly no one trusts you and therefore
we aren't able to offer you a spot on
the team however we think it would be an
abomination
to burn bridges
with you so we would like very much to
offer you a job as our strength
conditioning and poetry coach
regards wow
so they let them down easy you know back
when i was applying to colleges it was
like it was like a handwritten letter on
no stationery just addressed from my mom
and dad being like there's no money son
there's no you can't go to college we
intercepted this application before you
send it in we're sending it back and
it's such interception uh well i got the
letter that's being sent to baron zemo
we all thought we would see yeah why
not
what happened to the poor guy uh dear
baron zemo we appreciate your recent
application to join the thunderbolts at
this time we are unable to offer you a
full-time position on the team pending
the ongoing litigation you face in
wakanda oh that's well yeah
in the meantime we will add you to our
wait list and invite you to join our
junior varsity league called val's pals
oh that's cute i want to be a veil pal
once your trial is complete please feel
free to reapply also sorry to hear about
the loss of your family oh so sad it's
really sensitive
so that's sincerely val regards regards
value i think that was really nice that
i think it was cool that they're sending
rejection letters to these guys a lot of
them are unstable and they and they
don't think uh you know they don't use
better help the way that they should
they don't use better help they don't
use the code break room to get 10 off a
month of better health
break room being the code again that you
have to enter when you're signing up
and for that
all they have are these letters so i'm
glad that we did that i feel better
about myself
it looks like coy's winning for his
abomination letter and i'm going to let
you know a little secret i wrote that
right
here
i know
so many
jessica
get back over here
as gwyneth paltrow oh yeah you have to
give a motivational speech as gwyneth oh
perfect okay
get that goop
hi
so
i know that you're thinking i'm so
depressed today
and to that have you tried shoving a
jade egg
up your cooter oh my god someone clipped
me off i know what you're thinking a
jade egg how can i afford that
computer isolate audio you can
you can grab an egg hard boil it and
paint it to look just like an egyptian
jade wait a second
don't do that you can go to africa and
you can dig into their rich soil and you
can also shove that up your cooter i
know you're thinking gwyneth why are you
so weirdly problematic i was raised this
way
i'm from
florida
is that true i think the one there i was
married to the man that was the lead
singer for the
what coldplay yeah coldplay and also you
know what i don't really give a [ __ ] oh
and neither should you this motivation
when you're feeling weak
uh drink some tea but when i say drink
some tea i mean a nice tea bag whoa and
when i say a nice tea bag i mean
you know where i'm going my god
motivation this is the motivation i'm
gwen is paltrow i don't know how to
motivate him because i've been motivated
either way
have a nice day
do whatever you want don't have the
repercussions that normal people have
you can do it and make sure you log into
your goop account and donate fifty
dollars to me and i will use that fifty
dollars to do weird things
oh
that took a turn for the worst there at
the end thank you gweneth love your
candles
where do you put them
i leave them out i mean they've already
been put somewhere
my understanding that's how i greet my
guests uh thank you to all our super
chatters for giving us that lovely i
wish it almost landed on as daddy and i
was buried
that's what happens uh i'm i'm uh
predisposed to spin for gwyneth uh thank
you to all the super chatters quentin
sent in the super chat bought a
mandatory fun mug play the graphic where
did it buy guys play it again oh my gosh
uh
also
show ali's message show ali's message
because it's very important very
important do not shove things up there
unless it's a proper doctor and it's for
you whoa wolverine trying to get us one
more uh alex c senator super chat tva
has a nightmare department and could be
on the q realm oh we could get a little
nightmare mike chiro sending a red
guardian is red hulk oh that would be an
interesting little switch that's right
that's
all right and graveyard good old friends
to praise gordon super chat saying will
we well where will by night be the
introduction to the marvel comic run of
universal monsters i mean if feige could
absorb universal studios he would baby
god you would just do it right into that
dark monster universe we were promised
seven years ago i wish that dark monster
universe worked man that would have been
a lot cheated oh my god
and let's be honest the tinkerer is not
anyone exciting i just wanted to do one
that you know i felt for that guy you
should have switched yours with coins
i should have all right
we got one minute left we're so close to
another motivational speech
spin it spin it well do you want to do
one
i can do one all right well you spin it
you like spinning
we'll give you guys one on a distance
insane over here on the break room i'll
move again oh my god the chat is praying
for daddy they're praying it lands on
daddy
what does everyone say
for all the moms in the world yeah
give a motivational speech to all those
moms in the world young gravy oh my god
mom's out there
without you
we literally couldn't be here
you
have to deal with us complaining you
have to nurture us you have to nature us
you have to make sure we get up get
going and move on with things in our
lives and you get very little thanks
except one day a year you pay more for
stuff there's a pink tax on almost
everything and statistically you're paid
less frankly it makes no sense you're
expected to both carry us for nine
months and has raised us for 18 and none
of it
gets appreciated enough except for that
one day that people complain about when
it's over a weekend and they're like
what is this four days on mother's day
mothers
everything you do
is important and we appreciate
everything you do even if we don't say
it we love you thank you and anyone that
isn't a mother in the chat the best
thing you can do to yourself motivate
yourself to be better is to be more like
moms because they are a thankless proud
noble
hard-working studious breed and we
appreciate all of them thanks moms oh
yes thank you to everyone except moon
knight's mom great stuff oh that is true
that is true i'm so grateful to be the
official mother of the break room tom
the maximum
you are the mom of that that's right
i love you all yes mom does love you all
and we love you all thank you so much
for joining us here on monday in the
break room uh it's such an exciting week
we're past d23 and we're so excited to
digest all this news yeah we got lots of
great stuff to talk about this week
another episode of she-hulk coming this
week uh andorra is just around the
corner we had a whole android section
today apologies to andor we'll get to
that tomorrow uh join our discord you
can send in clips of the week you can
send in voicemails you can have fun
chats
go to newrockstarsmerch.com grab a mug
grab one of these mugs before we burn
them in a fire pit uh they're gonna eat
them to eat the video oh yeah we're
gonna bury them like the e.t atari games
out in the desert never to be found
again uh it's gonna destroy the desert
which was already lifeless there'll be
even less life because is destroyed at
all they'll be so expensive in the
future oh yeah totally worth it mint in
box if you can grab one keep it don't
ever use it because it will cut your
lips if you try to drink out of it thank
you so much join us here tomorrow at the
same time uh we hope you have a great
rest of your monday and we'll see you
again soon adios latest skaters
see you tomorrow
[Music]
so
[Music]
you